[Música]
estoy buscando una aplicación en mi
celular que me permita organizar mis
próximas vacaciones
será que para todos los problemas
cotidianos existe una aplicación o app
como le llaman ahora que nos ayude a
resolverla
después de platicar con un par de
ejemplos
si eso es posible hace muchos años un
día llegué a la casa de mis padres y mi
papá tenía en la pared un pedazo de
unicel un rayado y tenía unas tachuelas
de colores que ponía sobre ese unicel yo
le pregunté que qué hacía él me dijo que
estaba intentando crear los horarios de
la secundaria donde él era subdirector
del ciclo que estaba por iniciar
yo le dije
yo te hago un programa que te lo
resuelva voy a la noche me pongo a
trabajar y mañana ya no tienes listo esa
noche me puse a trabajar y a medida que
avanzaba en el programa me da cuenta de
la complejidad del del mismo después de
investigar sobre el problema y entonces
descubrí que este es uno de los
problemas en los que no se puede
garantizar la satisfacción de todas las
restricciones además hay mucha gente del
mundo proponiendo nuevas soluciones y
por si fuera poco
existe incluso un concurso a nivel
internacional donde expertos en
programación de todo el mundo llegan a
proponer nuevas estrategias algoritmos
genéticos algunos para leerlos etcétera
etcétera quiero transmitirles a grandes
a grandes rasgos la complejidad del
mismo imaginemos que tenemos un profesor
un salón de clases y un grupo el
problema está resuelto no hay
restricciones ese profesor le da clases
a este salón en este grupo y listo
escalamos el problema a tres profesores
tres grupos y tres salones de clase cada
uno de estos profesores estamos hablando
de una sola materia le da clases a cada
uno le puede dar clases a cada uno de
estos
grupos eso significa que hay tengo 3 x 3
no hay posibles combinaciones ahora si
metemos los salones lo que tengo es 9
por 327 tengo 27 posibles maneras de
resolver el problema si esto llevamos a
la vida real tenemos por ejemplo en una
facultad donde hay la carrera toma 5
años en cada nivel educativo hay 10
materias aproximadamente
30 salones por ejemplo y estamos
hablando de 50 bacterias al semestre
por cada uno de estos salones 30 salones
con 40 profesores donde hay por ejemplo
profesores que no pueden llegar a las 7
de la mañana
por si fuera poco toda esta gran
cantidad que se va formulando están los
cinco días de la semana los horarios de
las clases empiezan de siete de la
mañana a ocho de la noche cuando el
problema puede ser tan grande que
si yo pongo a una computadora a trabajar
podría tardarse 200 años en darme la
solución no podemos esperar 200 años no
habría clases simplemente bueno cuando
yo descubrí ese esa cantidad de
problemas
allí decidí que quería hacer mi maestría
en ciencias de la computación la verdad
es que en este mundo tenemos muchos
problemas cotidianos de esta forma por
ejemplo
los cambios repartidores y si tienen que
llevar su producto
supongamos tres tiendas el camino
repartidor puede decidir por cuál de
ellas empezar una vez que decida por
cuál empezar le quedan otras dos en tres
tiendas el cambio repartidor
tiene tres por dos seis diferentes
maneras de repartir ese producto en la
ciudad no hay tres tiendas supongamos
que hay diez tiendas
la cantidad de combinaciones en los que
el camión repartidor puede ir entregando
su producto son de más de 3 millones de
esas combinaciones en una ciudad 10
tiendas son pocas
supongamos que hay 100 tiendas
el número de combinaciones en los que el
camión repartidor puede ir entregando
ese producto es un número que tiene 157
dígitos si lo escucharon bien 157 ceros
o sea ni siquiera sabría cómo pronunciar
ese número
hace mucho tiempo una empresa
refresquera conocida internacionalmente
se dio cuenta del problema que tenía
enfrente y lanzó un concurso donde lo
que pedía era que alguien le propusiera
maneras de repartir de ese producto que
esa empresa tiene la necesidad de
entregar afortunadamente y escucharon
bien afortunadamente existen todo ese
tipo de problemas
la próxima vez que ustedes quieran ir de
vacaciones se va a cortar mucho de esta
charla les voy a decir por qué
cuando se llegan a un lugar
vacacionar pues tienen seleccionado
algunos museos que les gustaría visitar
plazas que les gustaría visitar
y si quiere usar el transporte público
si quieren satisfacer los requerimientos
de su mamá de su papá de sus hermanitos
los horarios en los que estos lugares
que quieren visitar están disponibles
bueno el problema podría ser tan difícil
que insisto si podemos a una computadora
iceta 200 años pues yo no me quiero
esperar 200 años para poderme ir de
vacaciones y estoy segura que ninguno de
ustedes se quiere esperar 200 años
actualmente creemos qué
todos los problemas cotidianos existe
una aplicación que los pueden resolver
la verdad es que somos nosotros que
hacemos ciencias de la computación los
que trabajamos en el área de algoritmos
los que hacemos que esa magia sea
posible en un intento por ir resolviendo
las complicaciones de la vida con apps
por cierto el problema de mi papá
después de trabajar varias semanas
logramos tener un conjunto de horarios
donde él tuvo que ir a la escuela
secundaria a negociar para que el ciclo
escolar podría iniciar la moraleja de
todo esto es no se vuelvan a quejar de
sus horarios muchas gracias
[Aplausos]